herzlich willkommen zur ersten folge
minecraft maut auf meinem kanal hallo
luca
was ist das für ein projekt
wenn ihr wissen wollt wie das alles
angefangen hat was minecraft mord ist
schaut euch unbedingt die erste folge
bei luca an ist wird von microsofts 10
folgen geben jede folge hat eine extrem
krasse challenge neben beispiel wir in
minecraft zehn folgen und werden am ende
sogar das end machen also den ender
drachen besiegen falls wir das schaffen
da bin ich mir noch immer nicht sicher
wieder schaffen aber wenn du das sagst
wir werden jetzt mal diese höhle
erkunden die wir letzte folge gefunden
haben bei luca und leute ich habe hier
schon was gekauft bzw
ich musste etwas kaufen es ist wasabi
paste luca kannst du mir mal sagen warum
ich das tun musste
lieber max in der ersten folge auf einem
kanal musste ich immer als du wolltest
zehn liegestütze machen das heißt ich
habe mir dann so gedacht okay max finde
ich dass die ganze zeit machen muss dann
isst du doch einfach mal wasabi und ich
weiß glaube ich dass wir beide nicht so
die übelsten schärfe freaks sind
deswegen würde ich einfach mal sagen um
deine zunge unserem bisschen zu lockern
ich würde an seiner stelle bc fmp essen
leute oh gott also wenn ich das nur
rieche und wehe du nimmst mich zu wenig
oder spuckt es wieder aus der das ist so
eine ganz kleine öffnung ich nehm das
mitnehmen so eine messerspitze ist sieht
auch einfach hardcore unappetitlich aus
aber ich nehme jetzt schon mal eine gute
ecke ich mache jetzt einfach leute es
ist eigentlich schon viel zu viel
übertreibt direkt zum anfang und los
geht's oh gott bin fast die höhe
runtergefallen wie war es mag ich das
ist viel schärfer als dieses mal sagen
was irgendwie ist gott leute was ist das
denn für alte makau das kommt das kommt
jetzt erst richtig gut
ich würde es noch schöner wird ich wird
noch ein ganz klein bisschen nach
trinken ganze ein bisschen du bist so
ein arschloch du hast mich zehn
milliarden mal liegestütze machen lassen
obwohl ich die ganze zeit den leuten was
erzählen wollte junge
das ist so ekelhaft so richtig ekelhaft
weinbrenner stelle wirklich milch geholt
oder so wäre es an in rom passieren wir
wollen ja auch was schaffen leute ja das
stimmt ich bin übrigens gab schon
in der höhle so ein bisschen weiter
gegangen habe jetzt sehr viel kohle
schon geholt und wird uns jetzt gleich
mal fackeln machen oder unbedingt ich
brauche auch dringend fackeln ich habe
nämlich ja auch wieder auf wir spielen
ja minecraft mit schildern und das ist
halt echt ein bisschen crazy mit dem
shader dadurch dass es halt so enormen
dunkel wird aber ich finde das macht das
ganze zu sondern ambiente ihren
veranstaltungen
das heißt du sehr schön weiß ich ob es
das wort ambiente hineingibt nein gibt
es aber das ist trotzdem ist sehr schön
gesagt ok kommen schnell hoch lukas so
zum schlafen ja richtig ich kann glaube
ich für mich und sogar sprechen wenn ich
sage dass minecraft muss echt geil wird
also wir haben uns so viele gedanken
gemacht wie wahrscheinlich wir zumindest
es noch nie bei minecraft projekt getan
haben haben wir in der ersten folge
schon gesagt wir wollten wirklich erst
exit nehmen aber wir wären glaube ich
den ganzen mods dies in hexe gibt nicht
gerecht geworden weil wir nur zehn
folgen haben und mit den challenges und
so dass wir alles zu viel gewesen sagt
vanilla so ein bisschen uns auf die
challenges konzentrieren und deswegen
bin ich an deiner stelle auch direkt
schon wieder ein bisschen was essen sie
sind gerade fünf minuten gefühlt in der
aufnahme und ich es zum dritten mal
wasabi ich habe ca 400 millionen mal
liegestütz gemacht junge junge jungen
außerdem aufgerufen dem ofen gemacht na
ja ich mache heute reisen also der
zwischenzeit mache ich uns ein paar
sachen wohl bekommst der die gleichen
für moderat so viel dafür geben dass ich
einfach dein gesicht wer guckt ihr
einfach meine folge an
sollte ich einen kanal abonnieren ja und
in deinen folgen ganz oft sagen dass
meine leute deine leute mich auch
abonieren sollen das häschen
das hilft definitiv leute das schlimme
bei den wasabi die schärfe kommt erst
kommt erst ein bisschen später aber das
schlimme ist dieser meerrettich
geschmack am anfang war das ist so eklig
ich muss ehrlich gesagt zu gehen ich hab
noch nie wirklich sparsam gegessen
max daliegt eisen drin das heißt du
kannst du damit jetzt sachen machen und
ich mache eben noch eine kiste
das coole ist bei minecraft wir können
auch karten das heißt wir haben uns
jetzt einfach ein bisschen eisen und
dann melde ich mich wieder zurück magst
du bist du unter der erde ich bin gerade
da wo die die viele lover und fahren
jetzt gerade ein bisschen kohle eisen
was auch immer wir brauchen ich muss dir
was zeigen was ich mir gekauft habe okay
was kostet es nicht die neuen easy ultra
boost 2 milliarden sind die neuen
die ultrabooks ich würde es mal ein
stückchen bazany essen gewissen ein
cooler schulnamen guter gut dass
ausnahme ist ja leicht höher nichts ich
höher nicht sehr gut okay ich sag mal du
du musst noch nicht essen ich habe schon
gemerkt ich ein bisschen am leiden warst
also leute ich sag euch 1 nächste folge
bei luca wird es kalt so viel ich weiß
welche stellen
aber du hast es dir verdient also
irgendwie ist das projekt so wirkt
gequält ist so unsere sadistische seite
die da so von lebt irgendwie kuwait
wegen werde ich die ganze zeit wie tief
es runter geht
was war ich 14 war schon bei mir
beleuchtet ist hast du noch reisen dabei
gar nichts leider auch sonst könnten wir
uns hier im kleinen ein wassereimer
machen und den rest der lava schmelzen
aber die die fließe ab na dann würde ich
sagen suchen einfach nicht weiterreisen
alter schwede wissen mich fertig wollte
sich auf die leiter schutz junger weißt
du kannst tun können was kommt jetzt
ich hab keinen fall hatten bekommen weil
ich hab die neuen easy ultrabooks wasabi
essen schöne schuhe wenn die coaches
platz max anita jetzt wirklich mal
wieder was abs
auch luca wirklich ja ok nein du hast du
hast schon recht ich meine es die
challenge darum geht's halt bei
minecraft mauz und oftmals beugen
ich halte ich einfach mir die nase dabei
zu damit es nicht so schlimm schmeckt
oder so jetzt übertreibe ich aber gerade
komplett bauleiter und ist einfach eine
coole in der höhle
also ich mir wird richtig schlecht bei
dem geruch von dem zeug gerade und ich
halte mir echt die nase dabei zusätzlich
zugute dass ich nicht so schmecke
ernsthaft bringt das was mir nase zu
halten
ich hatte das auch schon mal gehört dass
es irgendwie bei gerüchen wenn man etwas
essen muss worauf man kein bock hat kann
sich an die nase zu halten dann riecht
man es halt nicht aber in manchem
annimmt dass trotzdem die
geschmacksnerven war irgendwie nächstes
jetzt deutlich besser gewesen du kannst
das ja bestimmt wer schnupfen macht dann
schmeckt er auch nicht so viel
es ist genau das gleiche prinzip
biologieunterricht mit kran crafter
wobei ich erkläre das ja nicht ich sag
ihnen oder so ist deshalb nicht wirklich
lehrreich aber ihr seid ja auch hier um
ein kauf zu schauen um nicht und nicht
um für die schule zu lernen
naja leute ruhig millionen überzeugt
gefechte nein du bist du bist du es dir
dein name nicht luca das sehe ich sehr
ich nicht machst du wirst nächste folge
ordentlich abkriegen er weißt du das
werde ich ordentlich ab kriegen wir der
einzige der farbton schmiedekunst du
bist der einzige der verdichtung ich
doch auch hey ich hab ihn übel tief
gehabt jemanden nein nein spaß auch
junge darüber macht man keine witze
naja du laberst eh wieder nur krippen
hier sind überall pieper
die sind so schwarz mit einem shaker das
heißt man sieht okay leute wir wir haben
jetzt schon mal die ersten reisen
werkzeuge sieht schonmal ganz vernünftig
aus so weit bist echt schon tief runter
gegangen bin auf 534 kommen noch mal zu
mir da kommt mir zusammen die höhle
ja aber da müssen wir die sachen oben
abbauen oder markanten immer einfach das
meiste mit
hier sind auch mega viele mops ich kann
nicht echt guten gebrauchen
ok wat ich kommt zu dir ich habe mir
auch schon ein eisen schwert gemacht
damit ich dich verteidigen kann
natürlich nur aus diesem grund luca das
ist da wo mein lover abgeflossen ist da
kannst du einfach den wasserfall runter
okay ich hoffe mal dass ich finde ich
gebe mein bestes
bei uns hier mal eine treppe hoch das
erinnert mich so sehr an ware an die
szene wo müssen wir morgen hier oben auf
mich gewartet hat ok luca ich baue jetzt
auch unsere betten ab ne du bist einfach
alles abkommen mit runter in die höhle
damit wir quasi erst mal so ein bisschen
farmen und uns danach so ein bisschen
ans erkunden der welt begeben können
genauer nächste folge bei dir würde ich
sagen so ich komme erst mal runter ich
hoffe ich finde es direkt ich würde am
liebsten die ganze zeit noch sagen ja
ist noch ein bisschen was aber ich will
ich jetzt halt nicht zu töten weil nicht
dass es so scheiße geht unsere
so ist es echt ich meine oder change
will mozilla com traf der jetzt gesagt
hast du ja ich dachte ich mir dass sie
die ganze zeit vor sechs jahren hat sich
die nicht vor dass ich nicht möchte dass
da was ist wo bist du denn gerade erst
jetzt wasabi aber ich bin gerade
untergegangen zu dem wasserfall habe ich
nicht gefunden
ich esse ich es nochmal wie wird es wird
mir richtig schlecht erreicht ich muss
jetzt auch noch mal zwischendurch
trinken
max warte weiter hoch weiter hoch nicht
der agando gold online elisabeth ich
werde nie wieder in meinem leben
irgendetwas was so schmeckt essen können
maxis zu meinen namen schrieb über dir
nee ich sehe nichts ist einfach also
schwarz wegen der shader also warte ich
hole ich ab ich sehe einen namen pate
hier komme hier hoch okay da bist du in
ordnung
verbaut und unser ganzes holz das ist
nicht so schlau hast du noch holz ich
habe ein stück eisen und ein halbes deck
gold nein dürsten stack eisen ja ich bin
die ganze zeit am um tigern
hier ist auch schon wieder so viel eisen
ich sehe echt kaum was mit dem shader
aber das sichert ohne das haben wir
extra ausgewählt damit schwieriger wird
damit so ein bisschen ambiente ambiental
ich mental ist er aber an thales auch
ein guter junge ist die mühle hier
riesig man wir können die gar nichts
zeit irgendwas mitnehmen wollen wir es
hier nochmal irgendwo ein lager
aufschlagen oder erst mal das ganze zeug
brennen was wir haben ja komme hier in
denen inzwischen übergang
weil dort wo bist du noch mal den
fackeln weiter die ich da platziert habe
hier sind astana wird klar sein hier
sind fakten hier sind fackeln hier sind
fackeln aber lieber hier so eine große
fläche da sind wir dann nicht so
eingeengt in seiner komischen band heißt
nicht so übel fiel hier überall wir
brauchen nie wieder irgendwie was holen
nächste folge können wir dann an land
gehen und so ein bisschen es nur so oder
vielleicht sogar auch schon anfang das
haus zu bauen ich glaube zehn folgen
sind halt auch für so ein normales
minecraft let's play am geilsten dadurch
dass man dass wir uns ja direkt das ziel
gesetzten jo zehn folgen und da
versuchen wir wirklich so produktiv wie
möglich zu sein aber auf der anderen
seite auch mit den challenges so viel
wie möglich zu machen und euch zu
unterhalten
dadurch setzen uns ja quasi selber
dieses ziel viel zu schaffen und das
würden wir einfach wenn wir wissen
würden okay das projekt geht 100 folgen
dann werden wir jetzt gerade noch am
spot- und würden uns ergehen sich
aufbauen oder so max ich würde sagen
jetzt hier so nochmal wasabi jetzt zum
abschluss der folge ja jetzt mal in
folge leute ich hoffe dass mich nicht
über gebe und beende jetzt mit diesem
letzten wasabi was ich esse die folge
ich also mein bauch fühlt sich richtig
komisch an sodass lässt im bauch schaaf
noch also es richtig komisch naja
wünschen guten appetit
ich danke dir lokal max ich habe
übrigens die ganze zeit schon redstone
für unseren für unsere railway nachher
wieder luca alles weitere können in der
nächsten folge besprechen ich hole mir
jetzt erst mal was zu trinken und das
war's von der zweiten folge minecraft
maut wir sehen es mal nächsten mal
wieder macht's gut und tschüss